you know what we should watch that I
never [__] watched on this podcast
and I don't know how I never [__]
watched on this podcast uh is [__]
are these things and I can't believe we
I never [__] watch it and I thought
it would be a good thing to watch with
you
um
I can't believe I never watched these
but to catch a Predators oh my God
these guys
well the way they try to lie is the best
[__] I was watching One the Pizza the
guy had a pizza he brought a pizza oh
this is the this was this one dude he
brought a [__] Pizza it's Saturday
night in the Connecticut first of all
dude how many syllables does the word it
have
it's Saturday it it it's it's Saturday
night in the Connecticut suburbs
Autumn is in the air I mean the way and
this guy the graphics bringing pizza to
the door ah so so far nothing this guy
is bringing pizza to the door and it
looks like RoboCop is looking at them
look at this oh wow the text but I don't
understand that these guys text these
things to who they think is a 13 year
old you know I could be put in jail if
the police found out we were intimate
that is that is
the worst thing to text someone yeah
because that that means that okay so you
know you know yeah you can't what you're
doing is really bad yeah dude this guy
is essay insecure when he gets caught
dude it's unbelievable so dude he
[__] is there and he thinks she's 13
years old she's laying it on thick too
yeah and she's laying it on thick dude
she's like 20 something or you know and
she's like killing it doing acting in
the meantime if I was in this situation
which I'd never be I would never be in
this situation I would be like she's
laying it on too thick that's a girl
who's been to acting class she's 22. but
this guy is hoping so much that it's for
real okay like a perv right
[Music]
telling the attack somebody here there's
somebody here somebody's so nervous
no expectations whatsoever no oh look at
look what he says
but look look what she comes in look
when he comes in
your jack fried yeah
like like he's the dummy yeah
with her who's her
I I want to know who you are I tried to
flip it on the floor why go back the way
he takes the water yeah yeah yeah
so [__] nervous to grab water
what are you doing here tonight Jeff
hanging out hanging out with who the way
he grabs the water yeah because he has
to do something
a little bit more about you first
can I eat first
ah could I eat can I eat first and then
he goes sure
he's so relaxed and convinced of his
innocence he eats a slice of pizza tell
me who you are because you know hey
who he is fumbling so hard with the
pizza dude it's so weird that this guy
chose to eat pizza in this that was the
weirdest weirdest [__] thing yeah
also for any of these [__] to
act like they don't know who Chris
Hanson is yeah I don't know maybe this
was this wasn't a while ago I don't know
I don't get it Boston man drives two and
a half hours to Connecticut to bring
pizza to a 13 year old girl that meets
Chris Hanson instead said Basics to
write to them
no [__] man well what did you expect to
happen
didn't have any expectations no extra oh
well you [__] definitely expected to
eat some pizza I'll tell you that much
yeah patience whatsoever no no so you
drove two and a half hours sure did from
Boston I like how he owns certain parts
of it you know sure did not a crime
against driving two and a half hours is
there right
who are you
[Music]
dude taking the pizza the cheese is
connected from the end to the pizza
can't get it off and just relaxes into
it and says
who are you
is the most
bowling like I actually think he could
maybe get away with it with that if he
was just that I mean he's
just like listen guys let's cut to the
chase who are you
eating pizza dude well he gets copying a
pedophile I know well what else is he
gonna do at this point he's [__] yeah
you have to just eat them at least enjoy
the pizza I guess last meal yeah your
dad to meet a young girl are you are you
working I will get to that in a minute
go ahead have a bite Soco probably
should have brought napkins
uh what a [__] demon dude yeah eating
pizza gets caught being a pedophile and
is like just munching on Pizza like that
yeah
yeah eating it like a [__] slot
somebody what's wrong with what is that
again coming to meet a young girl yes
against the law
yeah it is after this cat
how
did you bring some kind of a contract
with you
some sort of marriage contract he had a
marriage contract with him that he
wanted her to sign up again I'm familiar
why you enjoy your pizza
slammed him I should come see him on
Saturday
well since your mom isn't home it's the
best time to do it I would but only if
you want me to yeah
I mean eating the pizza
these make me hungry I can't go to jail
my life would be ruined right right
right right that sounds like me that
sounds like me right right you do agree
with that can't go to jail life will be
ruined
wow that was a good one okay let's see
if we can hear anything
my life would be ruined right could be
locked up for 20 years yeah yeah
could be like that for 20 years no
chewing
oh wow
I can see why you know a girl would like
this guy just his confidence you say do
you trim your black okay oh he loves
that oh yeah okay it sounds like me too
yeah okay okay gonna bring that up okay
great you're gonna bring that up
oh you know
that Scrolls 13 right
I wasn't sure she's told
oh wow I wasn't sure so he says he
wasn't sure how old are you
you might as well just tell me because I
can find out like that who are you can
you tell me who you are first
I will tell you that in a minute because
you know now you're you're making me
nervous and now oh yeah right you made
me want to stop eating my Pizza kind of
losing my appetite honestly
[__] pieces Pizza is eating housing
that pizza yeah two and a half hour
drive [__] housing that pizza what I
mean housing yeah [__] housing he is
[__] it's like
a tree trimmer or like a [__] what do
they call them tree what do you call log
[__] yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm talking
to 13 year old girls like this you don't
want to
what am I supposed to make of that
for me to me no potentially having sex
oh okay so I mean first of all well I
don't understand these guys when this
guy shows up how do you not leave Matt
broke the set
how do you not leave immediately
just leave when that happens immediately
right
uh yes I don't know dude I don't I don't
well he's he's so he is so
[__] scared yeah well of course he is
well obviously but that's that explains
every weird [__] up stupid thing he's
doing like his brain is clearly not
working he knows it's Chris Hansen right
he knows how [__] he is he knows he's
never gonna eat a pizza again in his
[__] life all right or that's all
he's going to be eating or that's all
he's going to be eating and now I can't
stop [__] thinking about how my
[__] voice is sounding like that or
that's all he's going to be eating from
now on in [__] jail you know she's 13
don't you I have it right here
well you might as well tell me who are
you I will get to that
I'll let you know when why won't Chris
Hanson tell him who he is
because he he knows once he tells him
that that who he is and who he's with I
think he's gonna leave
and he wants to get good television so
it's just entertainment value yes but
also Chris Hanson didn't he have some
[__] come out about him why yeah you
didn't know about this you did yeah
Chris Hanson
uh uh what would I call it uh what would
I type in
bounced a bunch of checks
really Oh I thought you meant like no no
he did he had some like
some other stuff uh
26 years no he [__] it up and they
went free but also I thought he had his
own things where he was like
trying to
or something not no not young girls but
no maybe I just made that up I probably
just made it up I don't want to say that
no this is a story and I will never ever
watch this YouTube video that begins
like that never mind I hate when a video
says it's a thing yeah it's not the
thing dude there's some [__] just
introducing it yep get you out of there
yeah get your view count up why are you
in the video of Chris Hanson bouncing
it'll be like new Eminem song and you'll
be like click to be like what's up you
know Eminem came out with a new song and
I'm like that's [__] up to do that by
my buddy you know because we're friends
now right right right yeah Eminem yeah
yeah